[Musique]
c'est un nouveau week-end de trois jours
qui vous attendent quoi profiter de
diverses animations proposées à saint
quentin en yvelines pour en parler
mélanie poké bonsoir vous avez identifié
deux animations pour nous un peu de
sport et beaucoup de jeu le club mouche
de plaisir organise une initiation d'une
discipline peu connue la pêche à la
mouche une initiation 100% réservé aux
femmes c'est une idée de la présidente
qui croise peu de pratiquants de fesmy
alors dès 8h35 19 novembre vous
apprendrez tous les secrets pour pêcher
à la mouche et vous pourrez vous testez
l'après-midi sur le plan d'eau du
château de la ville la pêche à la mouche
consiste à attraper le poisson mais de
le relâcher tout de suite et en plus on
pêche avec des hameçons parce que i'm so
i lya pour attraper du poisson qui ne
font pas mal parce qu'il n'ya plus d'art
dit ion n'ya pas le petit crochet qui
est à l'intérieur du de l'hameçon pour
cela il n'y a pas d' appât naturel donc
on ne met pas les mains dans le pot 2
sticks eau ni à les sortir des verts des
vers de terre
donc on est sur une pêche qui est propre
alors pour les intéressés une
inscription et demandes et les
informations s'affichent en bas de
l'écran
pour participer il faut être âgé d'au
moins 12 ans alors le lendemain le 10
novembre ce sont les lui dit dave qui
débute à saint quentin en yvelines
et oui ça débute même à la commanderie
où il va y avoir des intrigues à
résoudre alors pour démarrer ce éludé
days il ya trois rendez vous qui vous
attendent
deux thèmes des skins game il y aura
aussi de murder party mais aussi un
espace jeux libres ces animations sont
sur réservation et on n'accélère pas
concerné spacieux qui est juste pour
profiter du plaisir de jouer en famille
ou entre amis et un dimanche qui lance
un deux semaines autour du jeu l'élu
d'ideye se déroule dans les médiathèques
de saint quentin en yvelines jusqu'au 23
novembre merci mélanie pour ce point
d'information ses idées de sorties et on
en aura d'autres dans quelques instants
le cetud ce loisir qui est présenté par
vous et c'est juste après ce journal